Prince William admits his biggest regret  over losing his mother Princess Diana in  a recent interview with British GQ the  34 year old royal opened up about the  loss of his mother telling the mag quote  I would like to have had her advice I  would love her to have met Katherine and  to have seen the children grow up it  makes me sad that she won't that they  will never know her William and Kate  shared two adorable little ones  three-year-old Prince George and  two-year-old Princess Charlotte and in  August it will be 20 years since William  and brother Prince Harry lost their  mother to a tragic car accident that  happened in Paris France  William revealed 2gq it's taken him  almost as long to finally be okay  talking about her I am in a better place  about it than I have been for a long  time I can talk about her more openly  more honestly and I can remember her  better  you